♪ 就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 多想多一点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见幻想 ♪
♪ 我想你想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
让我心甘情愿爱你
♪ 无心为你 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿 ♪
♪ 给你说个更好 ♪
♪ 你别演蜜 ♪
♪ 隔空传递 ♪
♪ 速上超多表情 ♪
更是一份最幸运
你们只要在身边
不需感谢你
♪ 我喜欢你 ♪
♪ 就和你甜言蜜语 ♪
♪ 在我心里还打call陷阱 ♪
♪ 甜蜜点心充满荆棘和自我怀疑 ♪
♪ 让我往昔 ♪
如果有一天
♪ 如果有一天梦想都实现 ♪
♪ 明明都成了永远 ♪
♪ 你是否在回忆的晴天 ♪
♪ 如果有一天我们都发觉原来什么的 ♪
♪ 可能我们是否还会停留在这里 ♪
♪ 听着像带了可乐 ♪
♪ 又一场想念你 ♪
再见浪漫不及待想你想你
♪ 你也唱过 ♪
♪ 放一首今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说句话 ♪
♪ 我收藏好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 独自不知道 ♪
♪ 我会好好音乐 ♪
♪ 花儿想想你想想 ♪
♪ 世界变成世为你自美丽 ♪
开始想着你自己
♪ 一直想着你 ♪
♪ 你在我心底变成了秘密 ♪
现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
♪ 你爱情的年轻的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦的一直 ♪
♪ 谁最难过的时候 ♪
谁在身边
♪ 你陪我掉眼泪 ♪
♪ 失败无所谓 ♪
♪ 我左右去 ♪
♪ 你的月光的美 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光的小姐轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 如今以后不会再在地上 ♪
♪ 你想想我感觉你在身旁的记忆 ♪
希望远远
♪ 你不要怀念一句是新的安全 ♪
各位媒体朋友打扰大家用餐
欢迎大家来支持王心凌全新的演唱会记者会
Cindy love this thing
爱心凌巡回演唱会旗舰版
我们预计在3分钟之后就会开始
今天台上的访谈
请大家留意
谢谢各位的配合
小火箭
♪ 你好像我的眼泪在往你的山海天花 ♪
♪ 我是一个只想在你梦中 ♪
日月和音乐
让我亲自去一天天的
♪ 真听得一点都不会 ♪
♪ 从来不会自在 ♪
一点睡意是怎么样
有老夫子啊
♪ 有你世界更好 ♪
♪ 你也有你 ♪
♪ 隔空传递 ♪
♪ 作上超过表情 ♪
恭喜一封最幸运
爱你呀
♪ 爱呀在身边 ♪
明星在意你
♪ 我喜欢你 ♪
♪ 就和你变成言语 ♪
♪ 当我体会打call陷阱 ♪
甜蜜点心
♪ 后来自己都不会 ♪
♪ 你让我忘记你 ♪
♪ 所以如果有一天梦想都实现 ♪
♪ 你在梦里都承认的永远都是飘在灰烬的起点 ♪
♪ 感觉如果有一天我们都发觉不原来什么的 ♪
♪ 可以尝试 ♪
♪ 不再会停留在这里 ♪
有当你的眼睛眯着笑
当你的可乐
当你吵想念你在飞浪漫
♪ 不知道想你想你还能穿过心爱 ♪
♪ 当你一首今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 问你说 ♪
♪ 夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
好好的说话
♪ 好喜欢你们知不知道 ♪
♪ 我会好好运 ♪
♪ 花儿想想你 ♪
♪ 向世界已沉睡 ♪
♪ 回忆自美丽就好 ♪
只想着明星走
♪ 一直想着你 ♪
♪ 你在我心底变成了秘密 ♪
到现在深深的深深的爱着你
♪ 是爱情的 ♪
♪ 年轻的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它去固定 ♪
♪ 很难过的时候 ♪
谁在想念
陪我掉眼泪
♪ 失败无所谓 ♪
♪ 你在左右月光的美 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光下 ♪
♪ 我轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 从今以后不会再悲伤一下双眼 ♪
♪ 感觉你在身旁 ♪
你是弯弯月光
♪ 你是幸运 ♪
月光花
以后会的情话多说一点
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 我想多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见我发的消息 ♪
♪ 一只想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
让我心甘情愿爱你更多一点
才会这么感谢我
♪ 只为你 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿 ♪
谢谢各位媒体朋友
今天来支持王心凌的全新演唱会
宽宏主办
今天的餐点应该很满意哈
连我的助理都吃得很开心哈
你可以来就位了吗
王心凌也要请你吃饭吗
你给我坐好好
今天呢这个演唱会的记者会非常的重要
因为对心凌来讲呢是筹备了两年
那对林宝来讲是等待了两年
不过我们也知道
王心凌对自己的作品是非常有诚意的
在前阵推出的基金选呃
My cindy
大家也感受到所谓life的感觉
一般life的专辑就是把life的录音
然后截取片段收录在CD里面
但是王心凌团队呢是整个重录整个编曲
然后王心凌自己也交换位置
仿佛站在台下看王心凌的演唱会
听王心凌的歌
那是什么感觉
而现在有个旗舰版电影演唱会要到来了
我相信王心凌也做了很多的准备
或者是调度
在2021年开春第一跑
现在我们就来看一下相关的广告片
稍后再邀请啊
甜蜜天后登场
惊叹感动常常爆满
全新舞台
全新造型豪华升级
唱回台北
王心凌dd love to say
爱心人巡回演唱会
2021旗舰版
1月2号
台北小鸡仔11月20一下午01:30正式开卖
宽宏艺术好
就在2021的1月2号
然后就在小巨蛋
真的是开春第一炮
现在就来
欢迎甜蜜天后王心凌登场
欢迎SIK迎接cindy love to six
哈喽大家好
早上好
来来先拍几张美丽的照片哈
来我帮你拿麦好
Cd love to sing
演唱会旗舰版
在台北小巨蛋好
请照顾一下每一台摄影机
谢谢放心
♪ 你用心为你 ♪
好pose再来变化一下
今天有一点点违性感哦
很可爱
然后呢又很漂亮
她的歌总是那么的让人心动
有这么多的代表作很不容易的
当然最重要的是
大家终于除了第集惊险之外
还可以再看到王心凌现场的演出
就在1月2号小区
感谢只要在身边好
再多换几个pose给大家
谢谢心凌
♪ 你在我心里和你打call ♪
不管是他的笑容
歌声都这么的甜蜜啊
所以过去我们都说哎呀甜蜜教主
现在不要说甜蜜天后
甜明星后的代表作
还有她的舞台魅力
欢迎大家2021年第一课就来清眼见证
在集精选当中
充满诚意的代表作全部重新编曲来演唱
有live的感觉
相信大家已经听得很过瘾
但是更过瘾的当然是直接到现场
看着心凌唱跳给你听
甚至大家来一个万人KTV隔空传递
♪ 合上超多表情好 ♪
还有哪边需要他的时间好
右下角麻烦
好恭喜
麻烦心凌言语在我心里好
左边再来一次
谢谢好
OK差不多了
可以好好谢谢好
来来来
刚刚虽然已经问候过了
你再见式问候一次好了
大家好
我是心凌
很开心
今天真的要把这个记者会很正式的带给大家
本音乐之前有发稿了
大家已经很亢奋了
就是没想到你在集精选
用life的概念做了专辑之后
还真的要办一个life的演出
是的大家敲碗很久了
根本说敲碗很久
很开心
就是嗯从去年一路这样
中间经历了很多让我们拖慢脚步的事情
然后终于嗯明年的开春第一炮应该可以
这么说是明年1月2号台北小巨蛋
我回来了
真的好
王心凌回来了
而且带来的是旗舰版的
因为这个cindy loves to sing嗯
等于是唱了
然后现在回到台北
然后旗舰版这是什么概念
你要不要跟他解释一下啊
其实啊这是我去年一整年在做的演唱会
当然是我上一张专辑的专辑
昵称CV的演出来的演唱会
然后可是一直还没有机会带回台湾吗
那因为旗舰版的话
其实我们从舞台从服装全素宴心
然后到我们这几次开会
甚至连曲目上都有
目前已经很多版
到了一个几乎我觉得可以是一个新的演唱会的
状态就很奇怪
因为如果你的title是cindy loves to sing
照照照理说
你就照着原来的架构
一舞台曲目搬到台北就好了
可是你却整个推翻衣服也是新的舞台
也是新的
都是新的曲目
也是新的曲库
几乎本来希望这是曲目的
就是大方向框架不变
可是现在连框架都有做蛮大幅度的调整
所以几乎就是一场新的演唱会了
所以是2021年的旗舰版
真的是为了台北的歌迷朋友对
然后特别做了一个几乎是全新的秀
几乎是全新
就这疫情真的大家太闲了
所以就就一直看不是吗
就没事就改一下改一下改一下改一下改
很花钱诶
没改一次就花一次钱
就可能啊
这个都要调度
等下你舞台服装什么的
然后就真的是大家真的知道
我从几经选一直到演唱会
真的诚意满满的
真的希望大家耳目一新了
好这么花钱
真谢谢宽宏的大力支持
让我们这个秀呢
可以在开春这第一时间能够被大家看见
当然我想王心凌的人生有很多很圆满的事情
你知道昨天同一时间这个舞台炎亚纶
他就讲他被人家说没有代表作
很可怜你的代表作可太多了
真的太夸张了
你看从慢歌到快歌
你自己有没有哪一首歌到现在在演唱会唱
还是会有一点bug
就是就是很不好唱
或者是很容易忘词
就是很容易飘
有没有这样子的一个大魔王在你的曲目里面
因为如果有的话
我那一段会非常认真看
到时候死盯着你看
我跟你讲这首歌
我现在还在考虑究竟要不要
他本来是没有在我去年的演唱会曲目里面
到现在我还在考虑
就是灰姑娘的眼泪
他怎么了
因为第一个哦
灰姑娘有没有科普一下
灰姑娘的眼泪是我们心凌第一张专辑
当时比较相对不红的那种
他是他算是第二眼美女啊
忽然在后面就红起来
你怎么会考虑到像灰姑娘的眼泪
这么冷门的歌又不红呢
不是他
是因为我实在看到太多歌迷朋友其实很会唱
灰姑娘的眼泪
真的
然后连舞都会都会大跳
或者是就是有一些留言都会留那首歌
我想说明明就我就红的
就不是那张专辑啊
那张专辑红的是当你怎么会一直痛的啊对啊
所以我不晓得现在曲目都还在点
然后而且你知道灰姑娘眼泪一出来
就吧啦吧啦吧啦
就是在唱有点音乐的那种
所以那个是可能是我心里头的一个关卡
对我也觉得有种我心我要克服心魔的
心魔的尴尬癌的障碍
你多久没有唱灰姑娘的眼泪
live的演出
5年五年后记得
其实上一次唱就是啊上一场的小巨蛋
然后再在之前的话就是发专辑的时候
所以中间就是这么两次而已
对不对
一直被遗忘
一直被打入冷宫
好看看这次有没有机会在新的演唱会
你要不要重新挑战一下自己的心魔
满足一下歌迷的需求嘛
好不好
然后再冒昧问你一下
我的助理刚吃自助餐
你会介意吗
哦我不介意
要吃开心要吃开心我就开心
我可以付了多少钱吗
大概多少钱吗
不过我真的对不起
我怕你有看到我就给你报告一下
中国同在的中国站在的经验吸纳人
你不要这样鼓励他
以后每一场都要在后台身败
打开布帘
看到他在那吃的很快乐
气死我了
好言归
言归正传
那么有这么多的歌啊
你要你要你要有什么样的新鲜
感谢大家
因为比如说嘉宾
这我们一定要问的嘛
是不是又不能透露了
就是这明星就要售票了
你要不要催票一下
一定是一个重量级嘉宾
会有OK好看好听
敲好就对了
对我想下跪
拜托他来
那一定是杨丞琳吗
你们最近有合唱新歌
陈琳有需要下跪吗
哦也对哦
他家是同辈的
要下跪的
就但我最近帮他唱歌
我邀请他
他应该很豪爽的就来了
因为他自己也演唱会
他搞不来要你的
所以你的意思是说这个人的辈分高到
你是要求他的那种
是当然不会真的下跪
那就要求他是这意思
蔡琴对不对
很不搭
这个太高音乐音乐哦
我真的也是跟蔡杰合唱的话
我真的是我妈高兴死哦
对你妈妈那个年代的对
但是这个很奇怪
还是你妈妈自己来
心凌妈妈以前是驻唱歌手
他再来唱一次
没关系啊
好玩嘛
这个你知道经过疫情
大家都觉得很珍惜
身边没错
好看是真的不能透露
男的女的可以总可以讲男的女的吧
男女不能讲不能讲不能讲
就是一个重量级
真的很重很重
前辈体重很重
而不是体重的重
OK那你会请他吃自助餐吗
不是一定要请他吃牛排吧
对面大餐好
敬请期待
我们不能透露太多
但是以王心凌自己对作品的要求
他的坚持
还有他一直想创新以及做各种变化
这个演唱会是绝对精彩可期的
真的这一次真的是我觉得真的完全是诚意十足
到时候大家看了可能就会知道
因为真的是会跟以往之前的
大家可能有些在网络上
可能会看到那个片段会完全不一样
完全不一样
我会唱
但你们会想听到的歌
我想唱的歌
甚至有可能是你们意想不到我会唱的歌好
请大家多多帮我们宣传一下
因为售票日转眼就要到来
也就是在24小时之后的猜测
好这是明天中午
怎么会在周51:30
21号的下午01:30
对这个一看就是算过的啦
没错哈哈哈
这个一般不是那种到假发那个熊般胸口
你即将不开心的可好看
请尊重长辈
我们尊重老师
对明天下午01:30
今天等于算是一个很正式的
把这个时间点告诉大家
所以明天下午01:30就要大家赶快去抢票
很少就是在24小时之后
希望大家帮我们宣传一下
那今天呢我们希望让心凌更了解灵宝的需求
因为我们刚刚讲心凌虽然自己准备好了
可是对林宝来讲
真的等了两年
尤其是台湾的朋友
对不对
所以特别我们找了一个艾琳特派员娜娜
来做了一个心凌相通大调查的VC啊
让今天的这个现场活泼热闹一点
最重要的是听听路人对你的理解和喜
爱的程度好吗
来请看VCR
Oh my god
大家看得出来我是王心凌的阿姨
我是娜娜大师
今天呢很残酷
我们来考验一下街上的人
就是对王心凌的演唱会期不期待
let's go好
因为王心凌呢有非常多的造型
但是比较缺少这四种造型
那如果在演唱会上的
我希望他用哪种造型呢
爆炸的爆炸性感奔放路线
爆炸奔放
这个好看
这叫侧边的吧
那如果你觉得他在歌曲上的全是有这三种的话
你觉得他可以诠释哪一种会比较闪亮
三姐好美吧
电音电音台妹
电音台妹不行
该最好看好看过她在节目上好
看过500个金句
好喜欢
你知不知道时间一只气
我一直眉
大概是这样
这两种你比较喜欢哪一种极致
你喜欢他京剧上的表现吗
演唱会还是500比较比较嗨一点
就是唱好了放进去放好看
哈哈是哪一首歌
爱你爱你爱你爱你是啊
可是啊
那先给你看一下王心凌的小小串烧
为什么爱你吗
爱你对对啊
那他是跳起来好看啊
对对对
忍不住唱首背会很容易
我从第一张专辑就买了
每次都会给他签名
你第一次给他签名
那你对他演唱会什么这么在抢票抢票
抢票抢票就直接会去抢票
确定会抢票好了
王心凌你们最喜欢唱或最后唱哪一首歌呢
唱歌好看哇
你看真的有诶
那不就是我的主打歌吗
我也会唱那个当你的京剧啊
好看笑好看
他的眼睛一笑笑大米可爱大米哈
好了好了可以了可以了
谢谢好了
放款阿姨要下班了
我们知道王心凌非常听粉丝们的意见
第一个答案就是
最希望可以看到炸奔放风的王心凌
那曲风呢希望可以在演唱会上听到苦情台语歌
音乐到大哥听
曾经访问王心凌这两个片段非常多人喜欢
但最终喜欢的就是上的唱法
王心凌
你听到了没有呢
粉丝们都期待你在演唱会做这些表现
王心凌
我们演唱会见哦
感谢艾琳特派员娜娜大师
谢谢看到这里面感触很多
我觉得像我唱苦情
他的歌可以
我可以挑战
但是那个爆炸头那个造型是在整我吧
好看很可爱
真的想看到我那样吗
麦克风投对啊
Why not
OK啦
上海流行吗
麦克风头不是流不流行
问题是因为你有的时候很低
比如说你永远是左脸这件事情
那你偶尔突破一下
大家会很兴奋
他明明大家很长
到现在就来突破
来换位置
看着我聊天诶
要脸的可以诶
好了好了
不要碰到你
不要闹你
所以演唱会知道要买哪边座位
买这边的
就是我在想爆炸
不是我的意思是说你要你可以就是突破一点嘛
我爆炸头不是不是不行
但演唱会上做爆炸头
就是那一段可能有个party啊
弄个水晶玻璃球啊
然后像迪斯科的那种感觉啊
对不对
好啦
我超想看好吧
你可以什么爆炸啊
爆炸头是很流行的
今年金钟奖有一个得主就是爆炸头
上去讲了很久
那个可是爆炸那个李老师
所以他是有流行的
第二个苦情
你真的OK啊啊
台语歌可以呀
你可以现场稍微有刚毕业啊
其实这种就差了一块好短
那个刚会有点一时间
最后我先生怎么看啊
好看你真的要唱哦
哈哈哈哈哈对呀
我现在要催票跟你讲
下半场你知道演唱会有多少吗
你知家里难道千万可以可以可以可以可以
要鼓励他
真的要鼓励他勇敢创新突破
你可以
我爸是外省
我妈是客家人
可是我觉得我刚刚那两句唱的蛮好的
你就一边外省
一边客家
其实比闽南语还OK的好看
加油期待你有这样的表演和宝贝
我跟你讲
真的竞争很激烈
然后讲这下半年演唱会
每一期每个礼拜都在反对
宽宏压力很大
那歌剧魅影的部分也帮我们多宣传一下宽宏
售票中真的他们刚刚后台压力很大
第三个刚刚讲到那个京剧京剧
那就是更是如虎添翼了
你这太因为他们那天看我就是上当了
大师的那一段好像他们真的就是很有感觉
对你来讲易如反掌
可以来一下
让我们我喜欢你
我也太好看了吧
今天不是你记者会
你不丢丢点东西给大家
人家要剪什么
认真来一段
从当年开始预备没有
就是这重点都是在第二次来
再好看
再一次我刚我不要吵醒你
还你知不知道照片都变成这张了
不会不会大家照片不用这张
但影片要用这一段好啦
这样很精彩了吧
很有诚意的吧
哦不过这个是四调八成的
因为娜娜这段失调是真的上街头去问
都不是C的
他们是真实的反应
包括灰姑娘的眼泪等等的
大家对你的期待和支持
还有就是希望的一些愿望好
我会回去再看看有没有更多版的那个rundown的
感谢好看
反正到1月2号之前可能还有不同的变化
但最重要的就是一个旗舰版
台湾的歌迷有福了
希望媒体朋友帮我们宣传明天的中午啊
11.30分
10月21号即将馆开始售票售票系统
那我们刚刚讲了这么多
其实都有彰显到一件事情
就是在歌坛这些年来
心凌真的是一个最强神曲的发电机
那不管是快歌
像我们刚听
当你啊啊不当你是慢歌啦
爱你呀
honey啊
新电芯啊
慢歌包括近期的大棉啊
然后到嗯我会好好的月光
这些都是我们会不经意哼起来的
我们用一个仪式来献给你好吗
来请看我们哇
这个是英语
这个带着后冠的最强发电机
然后有一个大爱心
上面有很多你的代表作
稍后呢请你转一下发条
这个是可以动的
对好来
因为你要准备上紧发
我也拿好了
来不拿麦好准备上紧发条
迎接演唱会到了
我们先拍一张
还没有亮灯的哈
好先拍一张
这些歌都是我们脍炙人口的啊
不管是我们在KTV里面高歌的金曲
或者是非常浪漫的一些回忆杀
甚至很甜蜜的啊
这些甜蜜杀快歌都让我们拥有好多的回忆
谢谢王心凌的努力
是要在这么多年来打造了这么多的经典作品
当然最好是到现场去听
刚刚只讲了几首
因为上面还有好多睫毛弯弯哦
然后这个啊灰姑娘的眼泪也还是又在榜上了
哈哒哒哒哈
那年夏天宁静的海都是非常棒的歌曲
好我们三秒钟之后
请心凌啊转动一下这个发条哦
好准备
各位朋友
我们再次认证华语歌坛最强金曲发电机
就是王心凌321
好把灯亮起来
干净喷出来
干杯还是彩色的
我也看到了
再跳一次好看
下面也会好
请拍照请拍照
♪ 我喜欢你 ♪
♪ 想和你甜言蜜语 ♪
在我心里非常的金属发电机
就是王心凌
不管是快歌慢歌
他都能够一手掌握
太厉害了
欢迎大家1月2号台北小巨蛋线
好看有哪边需要视线好
右边一点钟方向好
中间我们心凌是临死角的啦
不是结果也美好看
还有那边
欢迎大家一起来支持抢票只有一场哦
而且还有重量级嘉宾
令人期待
节目呢一直在改变
不到最后一刻
绝对要做出最好的调整
最后一天才会告诉你会有多精彩好
还有哪边
谢谢好
看啦今天的发布呢
差不多讯息都分享完毕
你自己看完之后有什么有什么感触
我看你一直在瞄这些
对我在看
从从古至今对对
从小时候到现在
最新的灰姑娘为你啊
对十几2003 17年2003
然后青春迷失的咖啡馆
2003年2月的时候
27已经快18年了
时间过得好快
然后就是更新的歌
对雷劈你的雷正在路上
也是非常好听的歌
因为大面积比较小
对现在女巫小屋
在青春迷失的咖啡馆
这都是我们大家的集体回忆啊
非常了不起
今天整个过程真的蛮感谢
我刚看到娜娜那段是最有感觉的
因为如果是20年前
就是我扮女装在街头很开心
我走到今天
但第二个我要讲一下这个道具有点可惜
为什么不每一首歌都是立体的宽宏
真的神仙神道
你看没有啦
很快要再把它突出来好看
可能觉得全秃的话
就其他歌就完全糊在一起
没有被凸显
你还真会帮主办单位审好看好的天后
再次的谢谢大家多年来对甜蜜天后的支持
来展示说感谢的话的时候了
对感谢谢大家今天前来
然后呃其实真的也很开心
2020年一直是一个
这么就是让大家真的觉得很不解啊
很动荡
很无常的音乐
然后可是很幸运的啊
我们控制得很好
所以大家又可以齐聚一堂呃
也所以明年1月2号的演唱会
我又可以跟台湾的歌迷朋友
台北的歌迷朋友相见
那还有其他各地的朋友呢
请你们等我
然后希望疫情能够赶快过去
能够更加的稳定
然后可以到各地去带着我的演唱会再去找你们
谢谢真的好期待这个巡回继续循环下去
不过我们先从台北开始了哈
先让心凌回家表演给乡亲朋友看
谢谢心凌的努力
感谢团队
谢谢宽宏艺术的举办哈
你知道现在最开心的是谁吗
谁我的助理最经拿菜吃了
好看在哪
甜点还没吃
对不对
还没有吃甜点
不要再演了
好看对不起啊
真不好意思
我回家反唱歌
咯叽咯叽可以可以
谢谢你好看
谢谢心凌的这个演唱会的举办
让我们可以听到很多经典好歌
祝福甜蜜天后秒杀对明星
今天开到01:30
谢谢cc ccc
谢谢感谢
点半开麦哦
再过来一点的好
我们再拍一张
换个位置吗
好来好
道具真的做的很美
我们应该多拍几张哈
跟着这些凸出来的字来一下这个位置
那个皇冠那边哦
破罐那边哦
这个构图
谢谢大哥帮我们构图了一张
戴上后冠
感谢的王心凌好
请大家继续支持my cindy吉精选
还有爱心凌巡回演唱会
明天周30月20一下午01:30分正式抢票
欢迎大家多多的支持
必看必看
2021必看的第一场演唱会
啊还有那边今天穿的很帅气
又有一点违性感
其实心凌是很多变的
期待他真的能够实现歌名的许愿
大家敲碗
想看爆炸头
想听苦情歌
想要有京剧的翻唱的片段
♪ 是否还会好看 ♪
有哪边
如果有一天我们都好
右边再麻烦一下
好好中间可以
心凌的歌总是这么的甜啊
就算是很疗伤的歌
都让我们觉得暖暖的好
谢谢大家
谢谢我们让心凌补个妆
测一下道具
待会再做电子媒体联访
谢谢